hey this is press to
Walker this video will cover two
different problems where X is in the
exponent of an
equation problem one solve for real
values of X such that 9 to the^ of x +
12 ^ of X is equal to 16 to the power of
X problem two solve for real values of x
such that 8 ^ xus 2 ^ x all over 6 ^ of
xus 3 to ^ x is equal to
2 pause the video if you'd like to give
these problems a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve these
[Music]
problems let's get started with problem
one
the first thing we'll do to this
equation is we will divide each side of
the equation by 9 the power of X this
will mean that each term is divided by 9
the^ of X now 9 power x / 9 ^ x will be
equal to
1 then 12 ^ x / by 9 to ^ of X can be
Rewritten as 12 over 9 to the power of x
16 ^ x / 9 ^ x can also be Rewritten as
16 over 9 to the power of
X now 12/ 9 is equal to 4 over3 we can
substitute that
in and 16/9 is equal to the square of 4
over3 so we will substitute that
in now we have 4 over3 squared and this
is rais to the power x where X is a real
number so if we're raising a power two
or power we can multiply the exponents
so this is equal to 2 *
X we now make a
substitution let U be equal to 4 over3
raised to the power of
X then the square of U will be equal to
that square which is equal to 4 over3
raed to the^ of 2x
so we can substitute these variables in
we now have a simple equation 1 + U is
equal to u^ 2 we can rewrite this as 0
is equal to U ^2 - u -
1 we now will apply the quadratic
formula U is equal to 1 plus orus the <
TK of 1^ 2 - 4 * 1 * 1 all over 2
multili 1
this gives two possibilities 1 plus orus
< TK 5 all over
2 but now U was equal to 43 raed to the^
X and for x a real number this will be
greater than zero so we can eliminate
the negative value so we get rid of 1 -
< TK 5 all over 2 because that would be
less than zero so we just have one
possibility which is U is equal to 1 +
otk 5 all over 2 and this is the golden
ratio but again we're not done yet we
need to solve for
x so in this second equation we'll take
the natural log of both sides of the
equation since X is a real number we
bring this down to the front and we have
X multipli the natural log of 4 over 3
is equal to the natural log of U we
divide both sides of the equation by the
natural log of 4 over 3 and then we
substitute for the value of U so we get
that X is equal to the natural log of
the golden ratio which equal 1 +un 5 all
over two and this is all divided by the
natural log of 4 over 3 and this is
approximately equal to
1.6
73 and that's the answer to the first
problem now problem
two this is a very different equation
and unfortunately we can't apply any of
the tricks we just used in problem one
we are going to have to solve this in a
very different way so let's get
started first suppose that X is equal to
Z in that case we would have 8 to the 0
- 2 0 all over 6 0 - 3 0 this equals 1 -
1 over 1 - 1 which would be 0 over 0
which is undefined therefore therefore X
cannot be equal to
zero from here let's manipulate this
equation 8 is equal to 2 ^ 3 and 6 is
equal to 2 * 3 we can then use exponent
rules to get 2 3x - 2 X all over 2 x * 3
x - 3
x we can then factor in the numerator
and the denominator we take a factor of
of 2 the X in the numerator and a factor
of 3 to X in the
denominator from here 2 to 2x -1 is a
difference of squares we Factor it as 2
x -1 multiplied 2 x +
1 now since X is not equal to zero 2 to
X - 1 is not equal to zero so we can
cancel out this
term we can then distribute through in
the
numerator then 2 to the^ of 2x can be
Rewritten as 2^ 2 to the^ of X which is
equal to 4 to the^ of
x from here we will divide through by 3
to ^ of X so we have 4 x / 3 x + 2 x / 3
x is all equal to 2 we can then rewrite
this as 4 over 3 ra^ x + 2 3 ra^ x is
equal to
2 so now let's define a function f ofx
to be 43 ra^ x + 2 3 ra^ x -
2 we can take the first derivative of
this function and then we can take the
second derivative of this
function notice that 4 over3 to the^ of
X is greater than zero
the square of a natural log will be
greater than zero then we have 2 over3
raised to the^ X that'll be greater than
zero and then we multiply this by a
square term so that will also be greater
than zero so F Prime of X is strictly
greater than
zero what does that
mean that means f ofx is a strictly
convex function which means it has at
most two distinct roots to illustrate
this the function will look something
like this it can have at most two
distinct
Roots so we know that F of 1 is a root
by direct substitution because 4 over 3
+ 2 over 3 - 2 is equal
to0 now if x could be equal to z f of 0
would be equal to 1 + 1 - 2 which equals
z so this function f ofx defined
everywhere would have two Roots at X is
equal to 1 and X is equal to Z but we
know in the original equation x cannot
be equal to Z therefore that cannot be a
solution of the original equation and
xal 1 is the only real root and that's
the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of my your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh